foreign
this documentary by Russian State media
Praises a private military company
called Wagner the paramilitary group
operating in Ukraine has been getting a
lot of positive coverage
all this despite private military
organizations being illegal in Russia
just before the invasion of Ukraine the
Russian president denied any ties
Kiev has accused Wagner of war crimes
now as Moscow loses ground in Ukraine
the company is gaining prominence
news reports and social media accounts
show Wagner's men leading attacks in
eastern Ukraine tapping prisoners to
fight and sending threatening messages
to the kremlin's opponents here's how
the secretive company has come to take
on a semi-official role in Ukraine
formed in 2014 to fight in Ukraine back
then Wagner has since operated in Syria
and several African countries
since the spring it's been indispensable
for moscow's invasion of Ukraine that's
according to Ukrainian commanders who
detected its presence early on after
Russia's main offensive stalled in May
Wagner managed to take the town of
papasana Paving the way for the Russian
army to take several strategic cities
recently the group has been fighting for
the eastern city of bakmut
version
as Wagner slowly advances toward the
city Russian propaganda has been
amplifying its importance anticipating
that President Vladimir Putin could tout
a rare Victory after a series of losses
and setbacks
but Wagner Services come at a cost the
group has been losing about 10 to 15
percent of its fighters on an average
mission in Ukraine as dead or wounded
that's according to an estimate by a
former Ukrainian intelligence official
Wagner's Fighters are paid better than
the regular Russian troops with an
advertised starting monthly pay of
around three thousand five hundred
dollars compared to two thousand seven
hundred dollars that Moscow pays its
soldiers fighting in Ukraine
and recently the company has resorted to
unconventional measures to find new
recruits
in September a video circulating online
showed a man recruiting inmates for
Wagner in a Russian prison the news
agency storyfull was able to confirm the
location
a social media account affiliated with
Wagner identified the man as yevgeny
pregosian Wagner's owner and leader
pregosian has said he has visited
several penal colonies but he declined
to answer our questions on the
recruitment of inmates and Wagner's role
in the war
enlisting prisoners comes as Moscow is
trying to balance its highly unpopular
mobilization efforts with its need for
troops
Russian human rights activists estimated
that at least 15 000 inmates had been
recruited to fight in Ukraine by
mid-october
recruiting inmates has another Advantage
as the official troops morale falters
consequences for refusing to fight are
more severe for them
that message was reinforced in November
a wagner-linked social media account
shared a video purporting to show group
members killing one of their own with a
sledgehammer the victim had identified
himself as a former convict who tried to
switch sides and fight for Ukraine the
authenticity of that footage which we
are not showing here couldn't be
verified but progressions separately
said the man was a traitor Days Later
Wagner used a sledgehammer again this
time the group sent one to the European
Parliament after the EU branded Russia a
state sponsor of terrorism
the Russian Ministry of Defense didn't
respond to our request for comment on
Wagner's growing prominence in Ukraine
Wagner's rise comes at a time when
nationalist hardliners in Russia are
calling for tougher methods to turn the
tide in moscow's favor and the
mercenaries activities in Ukraine are
welcomed by pro-war critics of the
Kremlin
military analysts in the west say the
expanded role for an organization
accused of war crimes and one that is
recruiting convicted criminals is a
telling indicator of the perilous state
of Putin's War Machine
in December Putin said that the military
campaign in Ukraine was going well